[موسيقى]
فقد اننا شاهدنا ثلاثه امور اولها انا بعض
التكنولوجيا في الحروب التقليديه مثل
المنظمات غير المهوله او المسيارات التي
استخدمت في الحروب في العراق
[موسيقى]
الامر الثاني هو ان الحرب تسببت في طلب
كبير جدا للمال والذخيره حتى من الجيوش
غير المشاركه في الحرب والدول التي تزودها
هذه المؤن مثل امريكا او ايران تعاني
لتلبيتها هذه الطلبات الكبيره في الروس
بدات تنفذ منهم ليس فقط الصواريخ بل ايضا
قذائف المدفعيه
[موسيقى]
والامر المثير الثالث وان البعد قال ان
هناك بعض التكنولوجيا التي لم تكن مفيده
على الاطلاق مثل الدبابات التي لم تكن
مثيره في الاسابيع الاولى من النساء
ولكنني اعتقد ان هذا الكلام مبالغ فيه ولا
يعني ذلك ان الدبابات لن يكون لها دور في
الحروب او اننا لن نشهد معارك بحريه بعد
الان بل السبب ان روسيا استخدمتها بشكل
غبي جدا ولذلك فان هذا الجدل القائمه حول
سلاسل لتوريد العالميه لهذه الاسلحه في
النزاعات لن يتحقق وسوف يستمر بيع
الدبابات والسفن القتاليه
[موسيقى]